in uh north west
from the deal finding stuff against the
great guys marco and mike uh and darren
so do you if you're free i can i can i
can pop you over to the man they have a
little introduction i mean it sounds
interesting they can pick you an email
yeah absolutely yeah all right cool i'll
uh i'll i'll pass you i'll pass you over
to them now
off you guys go go and do some business
[Applause]
two seconds we just it's been a bit
obviously as you can probably understand
very hectic doing all this we just
started trying to figure out which ones
are which from the from all the viewers
we've got ackerington road burnley
acronton road burnley
okay
all of our all of our books and
everything are in the training room
yeah yeah so we've got one on piccadilly
road um
so that's in burnley that one's going
for sixty thousand
yeah yes that's the one
yeah yeah i've got your input there on
friday
we're going monday
[Laughter]
um we've got byron street that's also in
burnley so that's so that's four
bedrooms two receptions
that's a 90k that's at 90 thousand
ninety thousand so have you done like a
rough estimate of refurb costs and
things like your costs he's literally
that's going to be like the next stage
obviously we're going to start packaging
these and start off we've got the dsm
tomorrow so it's going to start being
like a they're going to be a more
packaged product to offer offer on
later on but obviously you know what
it's like with samuel on stage and then
uh yeah yeah
next thing i'm on the phone to you
but hey listen i'll tell you what i'll
do then let me leave let me lead the way
a little bit oh i give you my mobile
number that sounds fantastic how many
people are involved there's three of us
right there's three of us so four of us
including me sure
right create a whatsapp group yeah and
we'll ping the links over to you
all the links over to me and i will
spend
this evening going through them
i'll work out what i think that they are
compared to what you think that they are
sure work for you yeah yeah that sounds
great thank you very much
and then and then what i'll do is by
tomorrow when you go back to the dsm
you'll have x amount of deals or
potential deals viewings already booked
but then you've already you're already
gonna know roughly refurb costs and
you're gonna know rois sure so then
it'll be more of a package deal to pass
on won't it yeah yeah well it's just
easier for us
you need to know what you're going to be
potentially buying it for what the end
value is and what refurb cost is going
to be sure sure yes the number is
getting you need to be more than you
guys yeah of course it is because it is
work backwards so first thing you need
to learn is get the end value value so
what's the double value for a four
bedroom h4 in the area then get your
refurb costs
minus your refurb costs from your donut
value
and then work out a percentage of what
sort of profit you want to be making so
maybe it's 10 or 15 minus that ten or
fifty percent off and then that will be
your offer price right okay okay yeah
right yeah well i'll drop you a message
anyway voice though but here's my number
write it down it's all seven
create a whatsapp group introduce
yourselves to it and then send us all
the links over cool that's great yeah
because that'll be the best way to
maximize our time you see because i know
you're going to be wanting to go back in
but if the deals are good i've got
hungry investors that are sat there
waiting for him in fact there's probably
a few investors on that course
oh really
amazing we like the sound of that
so we might be able to sell a deal to
somebody in that crowd who's an investor
of mine
brilliant i like the sound of that
launch that's brilliant
yeah yeah thank you very much
our challenge was to find hmos um so our
patch was burnley
so
yeah we chose burnley um and then we um
we just got got onto the estate agents
we started our little plan we both said
all separated and then we just got into
the agents and just basically told them
what was looking for told them the
criteria the profile and the properties
and stuff 22 viewings we bought as a
total and all three of us so uh
yeah and then
they just started sending those lists of
properties so then we bought them and
then uh
got on stage we made it we made a we
made a decision as a group with the
start to uh utilize the time very
cleverly by uh splitting up into a group
of well from a group of three into three
individuals so that we could then
all individually phone different agents
so we could utilize the time better to
be able to get more deals to be able to
do the viewings
and uh but yeah and so we went in uh we
went back into the room and samuel said
keep your hand up until uh until you say
everyone else has put their hands down
and you've got the most the most
viewings booked and that was it was up
on stage next thing i know here we are
in front of the camera
doing deals i just got to be confident
and
just go with the mindset that um this is
going to work out you need to like
utilize your time as well you know just
and just get on the phone that's the
main thing get on the phone tell people
what you want and then go from there
the massive lesson that i've learned
from this is just if you just put
yourself out there and you just really
go for it you really believe that this
is going to work for you then the
results come very quickly i mean i i
haven't ever phoned an agent before
apart from when i bought my first flat
when i was uh when i was 18 and uh i've
done it today i've spoken probably to
more agents and i've ever spoken to it's
been a fantastic experience let's make
some money
no matter where it is you are on your
property journey this event is for you
you might be a brand new beginner who's
just getting started in property or you
might be a seasoned professional the
property investors crash course has it
all samuel leeds is a property investor
and entrepreneur he got into property
age 17 and by the age of 21 he was
financially free he's now a
multi-millionaire and he teaches
property investment all over the uk he's
well known as the uk's most inspiring
property investor and chances are if
you're watching this video he's already
inspired you there's going to be
training covering lease option
agreements hmos rent to rent service
accommodation it really is a fantastic
grounding for any property investor
unlike normal training courses where the
training is done at you samuel interacts
with everybody he makes live calls and
he gets you to do it too so you're
actually doing the do in the room there
are going to be people who attend the
crash course who buy deals that they
have found while they were there there
are going to be people who go on to
become financially free as a direct
result of what they learned at this
event and the best part is at the moment
it is completely free to attend so what
are you waiting for get booked on this
is the property investors crash course
[Music]